I don't know if you do those kinds of
conversations where I've never talk to
any country later so no not not a
country leader but say a controversial
figure or somebody that represents a
certain idea don't just talk in the
space of ideas or challenge the ideas
but understand who is this person how
did you come to those ideas oh yeah when
I've had there have been a couple of
very controversial Riot leaning figures
um so the two obviously the my
experiments maybe they're Lauren
Southern and Nick Fuentes and those
types of conversations initially aren't
very political at all yeah it's more
like like obviously we believe in very
very different things but like beliefs
don't happen accidentally so how did you
get to where you are those are way more
personal conversations that's true is
there things you regret about those
conversations where you failed is there
things you're proud of where you
succeeded for things that I'm proud of I
feel like I feel like I'm really good at
attempting to understand people without
judgment that I think a lot of people
feel like they can have conversations
with me where they can share a lot and
I'm not going to jump down their throat
for them having a politically incorrect
observation or for them being judgmental
to somebody else or having like a
feeling that's maybe not something they
should have something embarrassed about
so I think I do a really good job at
that and then by extension of that I've
gotten the ability to hear perspective
from so many different people that I
think I can understand a lot of
different perspectives
um for failures of mine I mean it's
always going to be
on stream it'll be like I didn't push
back hard enough or I didn't know like a
certain fact for a conversation these
are usually the they're going to be on
these like very technical grounds
generally I'm pretty happy with like the
direction my conversations have gone uh
recently especially over like the past
six months so your goal is to
de-radicalize the audience of those
folks and so that used to be my goal uh
my goal was de-radicalization now I'm
kind of hoping that that's just the
byproduct so the goal I think is to talk
to somebody and to show they believe
this because of these reasons and if you
want to change people's beliefs we have
to talk about the underlying reasons for
why they think the things they think
it's not enough to just say like that
belief is bad because it's like well
they believe it for a whole bunch of
things that are true and real to them at
least so you have to address all the
underlying things that they believe
before you can change the overlying
belief so if I'm having a conversation
with somebody it'll be like okay why do
you feel this about that that and that
okay I understand that maybe like a
better way to solve that would be like
this or that instead of this thing so to
what degree do you have to empathize
with the person's world view
versus pushback that's that's always the
hard one uh when I'm talking to other
people it's almost always me stepping as
much inside their bubble as I can I have
to like live and breathe their world
view and be able to speak their world
view in order to like navigate their
thoughts because my world view is um I
don't I'm not even used this as an
insult I don't know if I am a little bit
Autistic or something but when I break
apart things I just want to see like
study study study fact fact that's how
my mind works for everything that's just
that's what I like to see like um
personal stories don't do much for me
narratives don't do much for me just
show me like the data and the studies or
whatever but for other people I think
most brains are more human than that and
they tend to see things in more kind of
like uh surreal pictures that are kind
of painted and the brush Strokes are way
broader and you know they don't care
about the itty bitty tiny fact
um so if I'm talking to somebody else
and I'm trying to get into their head
and I'm trying to change their mind on
things I'm going to be stepping into
their world
and I'm going to try to be working
through that framework a really good
example might be
um we'll say like when it comes to trans
issues for minors okay 16 or 17 year old
needs to get on puberty blockers the way
that I want that debate to play out is
uh let's look at all the data let's see
what are the outcomes uh let's see what
are the processes for getting a
medication and then we'll evaluate all
of that and then we'll go in whatever
like points more favorably but that's
wholly unconvincing to most people right
so as a parent if I'm having that
conversation with another parent the
easiest way for me to have that
conversation is like hey we both have
kids imagine how horrible it would be if
we felt like our kids needed help and
the government was trying to get between
us and and their doctor and that
conversation that might be how that talk
plays out which I think that's a really
good argument because I think there
probably are times when the government
should get in between but I'll have that
conversation because now I'm in a world
where they understand what I'm saying I
am resonating with the way that they
feel about things and that I can make
progress with the way that they're kind
of viewing the world because I'm talking
in a language they understand